you've ever had like a breakup or a
quitting if you're an employee like
these things that you dread I don't know
if you notice it but like the moment
after you do it I'm like how many other
conversations can I have so I had
multiple partners I had a partner in one
of my gyms I had a partner in four other
gyms I had a partner in a Cairo and
dental marketing agency and all of them
relied on me to make money all of their
livelihoods were still dependent on me
but I was splitting everything and it
was just horrible for me at the time I
ended up getting in a DUI and I talked
to a performance coach or whatever and
he was like your stress in these
conversations could literally kill you
he's like they almost did I got a
head-on collision at 60 miles an hour
and I walked away no injuries but it was
like my wake-up call but not to stop
drinking it was my wake-up call that I
needed to have these conversations the
next day I had the first conversation
with the first partner and it was
horrible but the moment I was done I was
like I gotta call the other guy and the
thing is is I had this backstop of my
death of like you almost just died
because you wouldn't have this
conversation and so then it just gave me
this courage to just be like like and
whatever the reaction was I was like I'd
rather be alive